it really is and when he visited with us  this week he talked about  as a player he was just locked into his  opponent he didn't even realize what it  was  really truly all about those fab five  days but now  as a leader my goal is to make players  become the best vision of themselves  best version of themselves look at this  reaction  they get the points off the pitch by  jace howard  how about that happy for him  i've seen that 25 before yeah he just  looked up  jawad just looked up at you that was  fantastic  that's what family is all about total  commitment  enjoyment three-point play  yeah you're right seeing howard in a 25  jersey of michigan  that feels right doesn't it it does  seems like